o de mí es yo soy de anís vine para
cuidar de tu boquita y cuidarte fue hace
más de dos décadas que denis vela por la
salud bucodental de los enfermos en
terapia intensiva 32 es una paciente de
31 años con un histórico de leucemia
asociado a un posible cobit está
intubada y recibe ventilación mecánica
ella siente mucho dolor no es agradable
sangra bastante es una segunda puerta
para otras infecciones con mucha
delicadeza denis hidrata la boca con un
gel humectante después desinfecta las
encías y aspira las secreciones cuida
personalmente de cada paciente
durante el procedimiento un chorro de
saliva salpica el cuello de venice que
abandonar rápidamente la sala para
desinfectarse es un accidente recurrente
que no hace mella en su dedicación las
marcas de su esfuerzo están esculpidas
en su rostro
tenemos que intentar que sea un poco más
leve conversar con el paciente pero
sobre todo cuidar del paciente con amor
con cariño porque muchos de ellos sólo
nos centran a nosotros en su momento
final
nosotros sabemos la batalla que ellos se
enfrentan cuando están aquí es doloroso
para nosotros es una muerte muy
solitaria
desde hace semanas brasil registra datos
récord de mortalidad los hospitales de
sant pau no están al borde del colapso
denis que no descansa ni siquiera el día
de su cumpleaños lamenta la falta de
distanciamiento social en el peor
momento de la pandemia
en este momento tenemos que entender que
somos víctimas de un virus que se está
llevando a nuestra familia y eso no es
suficiente para que las personas se
concienticen y usen la mascarilla dios'
cirujana y profesora denise fue la
primera persona en brasil que recibió la
vacuna de astrazéneca participa como
voluntaria en los ensayos para ayudar en
la lucha contra el coronavirus